>>Nigel Morris: Okay, I'm Nigel Morris. I'm
the CEO of Isobar which is a digital marketing
network.
I actually don't think the environment is
going to lose out to the economy in 2009.
Partly the reason for that, is that the economy
is in many respects a subset of the environment.
I think people are beginning to realize that
the old models of mass, the old models of
producing things that we don't need, of consuming
things that we don't really need to consume
in the West is actually broken. And actually
people are beginning to realize that a sustainable
mode of consumption and a sustainable mode
of production are the only things that are
going to generate sustainable jobs, they are
going to create sustainable economies.
I think they are actually going to get us
back to having a real economy in a real world.
That's interesting coming from someone who
works in digital. Actually, again, I think
that digital is going to be the key driver.
That's because: one, the more and more of
the business processes the more that go digital,
the more impact they are going to have in
the physical world. Anything that can be done
digitally will start to be done digitally.
And the other thing is going to be enormous
pressure on business, on politicians to act
sustainably, responsibly, ethically, because
everything we do is now transparent.
Digitally is all about everyone being connected
to everyone else in anything they're interested
in. What we have is a world in which there
is a transparency of actions. That you're
two clicks away from finding out whether someone
has actually done what they said they were
going to do.
So therefore, I think if you look at the macropressure
of the last 20 years that's been about the
environment. That the economy is, it's a blip,
but it's a very big blip. But actually it's
going to be a tipping point that takes sustainability,
takes the environment really, really seriously.
It's actually a critical year for that.